hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with reason senior
editor Damon root about the three most
interesting cases in this supreme court
session Damon thanks for talking about
thank you you just were at the oral
arguments for a bizarre case in Florida
what's going on so this is a case called
Koontz for st. John River Water
Management District essentially it's a
state regulatory agency it tells this
this property owner he's got a small
parcel and he wants to commercially
develop but they say will give you the
building permits if you obey certain
conditions and you know that and the
main point of disputed between them is
that the agency said you've got to
perform off site improvements to public
land you know 10 you know 10 miles away
50 acres of public land so I want to
develop this part of land in the states
oh sure go ahead but then you gotta fix
up this other parcel of land that you
does he own it no it's public land yeah
and so he says well you know he refuses
to do this he sees this as extortion by
the government says you know the takings
Clause the Fifth Amendment says if you
take my property for public use you have
to pay me just compensation this is a
public use I shouldn't have to bear this
burden so this this case makes it to the
Supreme Court there's also a second sort
of related issue and which was actually
really was the big deal today which was
is his money is the government says you
have to pay for this for these
mitigations these all set improvements
does that count is a taking under the
takings clause and Florida and the
federal government said no cash
extractions that's not a taking and that
was that was something that the majority
of the court seemed to reject yeah and
you were saying that it you know I mean
it seems like an open-and-shut case to
me but what do I know but the the
Supreme Court had looked pretty bad
against the the plaintiff in this yet
the property owner had a had a hard time
before the court today and one of the
one of the things that was a little
surprising was the Justice Scalia who's
typically seen as someone needs
conservative he's in favor of property
rights and so forth he he seemed pretty
skeptical of aspects of the government's
case particularly the idea that there
any sort of taking occurred his argument
was if the permits were denied therefore
nothing was taken from you it's not a
taking you know this court doesn't need
to hear this case and so if he if he say
besides with the liberal bloc on that
and then they lose on that point
okay next case has to do with blood
tests or being accused of driving under
the influence yeah this case out of
Missouri Missouri versus McNeely and
this this basically says does the Fourth
Amendment which prevents government
doing unreasonable searches and seizures
does the Fourth Amendment force the
police to get a search warrant if they
suspect you have drunk driving and they
want to take blood out of you the police
argument the government argument is that
you know alcohol dissipates in the blood
very quickly there's what's called an
exigent circumstance exception to the
Fourth Amendment basically the police
need act rapidly to get this you know
evidence of drunk driving out of you
they shouldn't need to go to a judge and
this case was argued last week so we
don't have the decision yet but once
again this is this is an area where I
think the government overreached and and
it's probably no no but what is the
status of if you if you reject a
breathalyzer test aren't you in most
places seen as presumptively guilty yeah
that's right so why wouldn't a blood
test do the same thing if I if I say hey
no blood tests then I'm just assumed to
be guilty well the really the issue here
is is that the is is that the blood test
is more is more of an invasive procedure
and so that should that should the
police have to get a get a search
warrant in order to perform that kind of
sort of invasive procedure so what's
your read do you think the Supreme Court
will say no they don't or yes the cops
do need a search warrant I think they're
going to say that the government's
position which is that there should
never be a search warrant requirement in
these cases they're going to reject that
they're going to say in some cases we
can understand why you might want to
waive the requirement for search more in
specific cases but it's a general rule
no we're not going to wait for them so
and then the third case or it's actually
two cases is about gay marriage what's
going on there right so this is this is
sort of the big blockbuster at the end
of the term oral argument at March
there's two cases one is proposition 8
from California which was a popular
initiative that prevented the state from
recognizing gay marriage and then the
other is a challenge to the Defense of
Marriage Act specifically section 3 of
that which basically says the federal
government does not have to recognize
same-sex marriages that are legal there
it's a legal same-sex marriage in
Massachusetts but the federal
government's not going to recognize it
and so there's going to be one there's
one case for each of these issues so
what what's going on with prop 8 is
you know where where's the Supreme Court
leaning on that yeah it's very hard to
say where especially on Prop 8 where
they're gonna lean I mean there's
there's there several questions one is
just who has standing to bring the
lawsuit what that means is that in in
California cab the state of California
has basically said we're not going to
defend this law anymore they stopped
defending it in court so the backers of
the initiative they are now defending
the law and supreme court could say well
you don't have standing you're not the
government if the government's not going
to defend this law why should we listen
to you essentially and so that could
that could throw it back to a much
earlier decision which would potentially
just limit could limit the case just to
the to the specific married couples who
brought the suit could limit just to
California on the other hand if the
court was more ambitious wanted to do
something more historic that we could
see a right to gay marriage emerge from
this case this because what the issue is
is does the Equal Protection Clause of
the Fourteenth Amendment forbid the
state from banning gay marriage and so
the court could say it does violate
equal protection and then there would be
gay marriage be constant and so then
what about the defense Marriage Act with
what's likely to happen there I think
that's a that's a situation where the
laws more likely to be struck down I
think the I think we're you know because
there's some sort of federalism aspects
to this you know if it's legal in the
state level why should the federal
government be you know sort of picking
and choosing so I think that you know
will see a seat of liberal bloc most
likely joined by Kennedy Justice
Kennedy's got a record of Lawrence
versus Texas to be a gap okay right so
then we'll be in a kind of strange case
where liberals are saying no this is a
states right issue potentially depending
on how it's how it's what went with
property I mean they're basically saying
well California as a state doesn't have
the right to ban certain things that's
right i mean there's this sort of
tension on the one hand it's there
should be a national standard for gay
marriage on the other hand let the sort
of states sort it out i mean these these
are issues in tension and so we could
actually see sort of the conservatives
and majority on the prop 8 case limiting
that to California and the Liberals in
the majority and Defense of Marriage Act
protecting gay rights or or recognizing
equal protection from the federal level
after the Obamacare decision you know
how has that changed the makeup of the
court ideologically or has it at all or
is there still a pretty solid
conservative
and a pretty conservative pretty solid
liberal group or are things muddier now
I think it's I don't think it's changed
the makeup i think that the there's
there's these these two blocks i
meanwhat definitely one thing that
emerges that Justice Roberts is not
someone you can count on to vote in a
way that conservatives are always going
to like in terms of sort of a policy
outcome and that he's potentially a
swing vote in the way the Kennedy was
but then you know what am I takes on
Roberts all along has been this is a guy
who's kind of an old-school judicial
conservative he believes in judicial
restraint and Judah Twitter deference
deference to Congress and you see that
in the Obamacare ruling so this is
actually the kind of thing that if
you've been watching Roberts it's not a
total surprise that he votes to uphold
this kind of law but but we're still
going to see Roberts you know siding
with the Conservatives the you know
we've got an affirmative action case
coming out of Texas University of Texas
that decisions coming up Roberts is
likely to be voting against the
affirmative action policy in that case
so he's he still there's there's still
this recognizable conservative bloc but
he's a little more imply all right well
Damon root senior editor at reason calm
and reason magazine thanks for talking
to thanks for reason TV I'm Nicholas
you